[Music]
you're washing swipe here's a little
taste of what we've got for you in the
next 10 minutes Alex gets an exclusive
look at the tablet saving time on
hospital wards I try to find out how
long it will be before we're all doing
this to pay for things and we've got the
point-and-click detective adventure with
an old-school feel in our games review
welcome to swipe we've come to visas new
Innovation Centre this week it's where
they're working on futuristic ways to
pay for things with big brands from all
over the world they've got a connected
car sitting room and even a pretend shop
here all set to demonstrate new payment
methods but before we have a look at
those we're gonna check in with Alex
he's been to see the tablet tech cutting
the time it takes doctors and nurses to
read our vital signs the NHS has never
been busier and with workloads on wards
going up saving time is vital for Mary
and other patients regular check-ups
like this are nothing out of the
ordinary but where doctors would want to
scroll down notes a new system of scrap
paper charts all together I just pop
these around your arm okay thank you now
a tablet computer is used to monitor
your vital signs and scan your ears bone
as well each patient has a barcode on
their wrist which allows staff to
quickly save and compare their readings
let's just pop this here
designers claim the time it saves is
equivalent to having three and a half
extra nurses on shift and using the
tablets helps eliminate errors so let's
just record that
it's taken seven years to develop and is
now active in four hospitals you can see
that you have a much more readable
interface and you have information
that's all over the hospital rather than
by the bedside and you have information
that's available to all the people
within the hospital who would be
involved in that patients care you also
are able to give prompts and advice to
the staff who are looking after the
patient so you'll see that at the end of
the track and trigger school which has
been added up for the clinicians which
is done automatically where it was once
done manually there's an advice button
if they press the advice button you can
see that the advice is given which is
what the trust one's doing for someone
who is that unwell so here in Oxford the
system has already helped in a care of
over 80,000 patients and the plan over
the next 12 months is to roll this
system out at for more NHS trust right
across England with no sign of pressure
easing on the NHS could increasing
reliance on tech like this be the answer
I think that overall it's a good idea I
think it will improve efficiencies and
save time and there are a couple of
issues you know nurses will need to be
trained up very quickly and not all the
nurses are going to be tech-savvy so
there could be some potential issues
there okay Murray we're all done
everything for Mary it's good news and
positive school son sire so far that's
really good isn't it you can see we've
got a improvement over time haven't we
it's really good for the NHS it's a
different picture
and so opportunities to use tech to save
time or in high demand Alex Morgan Sky
News stay with us still to come how long
do you think it will be before shops
stopped accepting cash and cards in
favor of more futuristic payment methods
that's what I'll be trying to find out
after a roundup of this week's tech news
NASA's suggested finding a second earth
is not just a matter of if but when is
after scientists discovered seven new
planets three of which lie in the
Goldilocks zone of their son
meaning temperatures are just right to
support liquid water the key ingredient
for life fitness trackers that count
steps made headlines this week after a
leading u.s. scientist questioned their
benefits dr. Greg Hager from Johns
Hopkins University suggested the goal of
10,000 steps a day may not be right for
everyone and that the target is based on
a single and outdated study and
illegally streaming live football
matches music and other video is about
to get more difficult search engines
Google and Bing have signed up to a
voluntary code of practice which will
mean dodgy websites are move further
down in your results list stick around
for our games review in just a few
minutes we've got the indie game that
takes you inside someone else's phone
before that though you're joining me now
in this pretend shop with Bill from Visa
he's not pretend you're gonna pose as a
shop assistant for me now on you and
we're gonna talk about this biometrics
device it's how you can pay with just
using your fingerprints okay so let me
try it works alright so if I've been
checking out some hoodies over here if I
want to buy this one you have that as we
have this video in stock so I'm gonna
bring up the hoodie and instead of
taking out your card or even tapping
your phone all you need to do to make
the purchase is swipe your hand on the
device don't touch it no just swipe your
hand and that's reading my fingerprint
it's read your fingerprints and in a
couple of seconds payment confirmed
checkmark payment done by Jemma Morris
and when we talk about biometric
technology what what is it that we
actually mean by that biometric is
anything that's unique about you that we
can use to identify you and you make a
payment so this is an example of
fingerprints but we've used iris
recognition because your irises are
unique facial recognition and in fact
today even the way you walk we've
discovered the way you walk is as unique
as your fingerprint individual
individual how long do you think it will
be and
shops don't accept cash or cards anymore
I think some of the more innovative
shops because we're already starting to
talk to them we'll start building in
things like facial recognition or or the
next generation for fingerprints and I
think this is just the beginning of a
long journey where we can authenticate
you based on things that only you have
now I'm done with the shops I want to
drive home unfortunately this isn't my
car it looks just like a tablet stuck to
the middle of the car right so in this
case this is a prototype let me show you
it works you want to buy fuel because
the sensors in your car tell you that
you're running low on petrol and it
starts to find the service stations for
you this you can fill it up and even
before you get there you may be hungry
and it adds the option of adding
refreshments now you're just encouraging
us to eat junk food or maybe something
healthy but I could just use an app on
my phone to look for the nearest petrol
station can I no I think that's right
and but I think what this does is take
that experience kind of several steps
further we've driven home now and we're
in this pretend sitting room because
bill you're gonna talk to me about
bringing banking into our homes we built
banking services into echo Alexa open
voice Bank welcome to your bank account
how can I help send mom $100 in canada i
have sent your or to is in undefined
using visa direct it will be in the bank
account in five minutes one of the big
criticisms though with voice automated
systems is the idea that Amazon or
Google or whoever's manufactured the
device could be constantly listening to
us in our homes does that freak you out
we look at issues around personal
information and privacy so that while
you're you know conducting a banking
transaction using Amazon echo they're
not collecting that data who is it that
drives the change is it the banks or is
it the shops because you've got to have
that ecosystem where everybody's
compatible you know more recently we've
seen companies like Amazon or companies
like Google or companies like Apple or
the car manufacturers all join this
ecosystem to create new user experiences
take the friction out of commerce and so
we'll see that ecosystem continue to
grow video games time now and this week
we put Gavin the hot seats and he picked
us a pretty eclectic mix I've been
playing this game called normal
lost phone which is basically you found
a phone and you get to go through it
which kind of is everyone's dream like I
found a phone before but it's been
locked so I haven't been able to go
through it but this is completely
unlocked and it's a guy's phone you're
not sure who he is will happen to him
why he's lost his phone and you
basically have to go through all his
messages and his emails and his photos
and things like that and you're kind of
piecing together this weird little
mystery you're never quite sure what's
going on with it
I still haven't completely figured out
what it is but it's like these weird
little puzzles in a way you have to work
out the Wi-Fi code for the area you're
in and when that happens then you unlock
a little bit more so it's not just
reading messages and being nosey and
really excited to sort of find out the
actual mystery of it because I have all
these different ideas but if it's going
where I think it's gonna go it's really
really good
simba we park is a point-and-click
adventure which is done by Ron Gilbert
who made probably the best
point-and-click adventures ever like the
first two Monkey Island games its kind
of it kind of presents itself as a
murder mystery game but actually it's
less like that and more sort of kind of
working out what's going on in the world
you have this weird sort of dead clown
who's cursed and he's trying to sort of
figure out what happened to him and you
all saw these like weird sort of x-files
FBI agents it's a point and click game
like when was the last time we had a
really good one of those and we haven't
that's the thing but Ron Gilbert is the
guy who can do it and it's really really
good I played a really really early
build of it but it's coming out this
year and I think it's gonna be a good
one so banned footage vol 2 is resident
evil 7 second batch of DLC and to be
honest they're just doing whatever they
want Resident Evil sevens quite a
serious horror game and then you have
these sort of molded characters wearing
party hats and things like that like I
don't know what is going on in the
Capcom studios but they seem to be just
having a laugh with Resident Evil 7
which is good there is a story sort of
mode with but it's only about 20 minutes
long and that's kind of like a little
precursor to the next bit of DLC we're
gonna have which you know it's really
really gonna tie into the main storyline
and that's the one that everyone's been
thinking about but it is just really
good to see people just having a laugh
with their DLC which not many developers
do
well that's it for this week but don't
worry if you've just caught the end of
swipe you can catch up with any of our
episodes on demand in all the usual
places so I'll be back next week I hope
you can join us and bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]